ya hemos cubierto la noción del área
entre la curva james y el eje x
utilizando una integral definida pero
esta vez pensaremos en el área entre dos
curvas así que imagina que queremos
encontrar el área de la región desde x
igual a am hasta x igual la vez en tremp
que igual a fx y que igual a gtx es
decir esta área que apoya a sombrear
ahora basándonos en lo que ya sabemos
sobre integrales definidas como podemos
encontrar esta área tal vez podemos
pensar en encontrar el área bajo la
curva
desde aaa hasta b de fx de x obteniendo
toda esta área de color amarillo bajo la
curva
y sobre el eje x y xi a esa área le
restó el área de color verde que se
integra al definida de aa ver deje de x
de x entonces me quedo con el área que
estoy buscando que en este caso es el
área de color blanco y de hecho esta es
la forma de encontrarla ahora sabemos
por las propiedades de las integrales
que esto es lo mismo que la integral de
a a b d efe de x menos gdx de x bien es
necesario que aclare algo en este vídeo
vamos a desarrollar nuestra instrucción
sobre cómo obtener el área entre dos
curvas pero ojo esta expresión que
obtuvimos la integral definida de aavv
df de x - gtx de x funciona si fx es
mayor que gdx como en este caso y
seguramente te preguntarás oye qué pasa
cuando no tenemos ambas funciones arriba
del eje x que pasa por ejemplo en el
caso en el que fx está por encima del
eje x y gdx está por debajo del eje x
por ejemplo pensemos en este intervalo
de aquí donde aquí tenemos a x igual ac
jac a ax walla dee como podemos
encontrar la expresión para esta área
sombreada de color
toda esta área de color rosa será que
funcionará la misma expresión pensemos
en el área que obtenemos de la integral
de cea del df de x de x bueno pues es
justo esta área de aquí y pensemos en el
área que obtenemos de la integral de c a
d dgt x de x
bueno tal vez estés tentado a decir que
es esta área de aquí pero recuerdan en
esta parte gtx está por debajo del eje x
por lo tanto toma valores negativos si
queremos el área total tenemos que tomar
esta primera área de color azul claro
que va a estar en el área de color rojo
es así como obtendrás esta área total
positiva y puedes observar que esta es
simplemente la integral deseada df tx -
gtx de x así que de nuevo en este caso
funciona también esta expresión donde fx
está por encima del eje x de x está
debajo del eje x obtuvimos la misma
expresión bien es momento de ver otro
escenario más el último en el cual tanto
f x como que de x están debajo del eje x
imagina que queremos tomar el intervalo
desde m x igual a me estoy quedando sin
letras directa desde x igual a m hasta x
igual a n y quiero esta área de aquí
estamos viendo un intervalo donde f es
mayor que g pero ambas están debajo del
eje x como podemos encontrar la
expresión para esta área sombreada será
que funciona la misma expresión bien
pensemos un poco si queremos evaluar la
integral definida de emea n de fx menos
que de x de x ya sabemos por nuestras
propiedades de las integrales que ésta
es igual a la integral desde m hasta n
de fx de x menos la integral desde m
está en el eje de x de x bueno la
integral de color amarillo nos da esta
área así que aquí vamos a obtener una
área con un valor negativo pero podemos
decir que el valor absoluto nos da esta
área de aquí
y ahora está integral de color verde sin
contar el signo de menos fuera de la
integral nos da el negativo de esta área
que estoy coloreando pero si tomamos el
signo negativo de esta integral toda
esta parte nos está dando justo el área
que buscamos el área de color verde de
hecho obtenemos un valor positivo porque
estamos tomando el negativo de un área
negativa entonces para obtener esta área
que queremos de color blanco tenemos que
tomar el área de color verde y restarle
el área de color amarillo por lo tanto
si tomas la suma del área de color verde
que ya sabemos que es el negativo de
esta integral es decir esta expresión
completa de color verde más la integral
de color amarillo que ya sabemos que es
el área en amarillo pero negativa vamos
a obtener el área de color blanco que
buscábamos y ahora si podemos concluir
que si tomamos un intervalo donde ftx
sea mayor a gtx entonces el área entre
las curvas es simplemente la integral
definida
ese intervalo de fx 7x de x hasta la
próxima